this video is brought to you by
Squarespace stick around until the end
of the video to learn more about an
offer they're making available through
my channel
so guys I've been feeling a little bit
burned out lately now I know how
sympathetic and supportive you guys all
are you're always sending me supportive
messages anyways so I can already hear
you down in the comments sending your
messages of support and it's greatly
appreciated however that said it's not
really necessary because I've been
burned out before I'll be burned out
again and it's kind of normal and that's
one of the purposes of me wanting to
make this video just to normalize being
burned out and to say that it is okay
from time to time to need to take a
break and that's especially true if
you're someone who works hard but also
if you're someone who trains hard
because training is a stressor and any
stressor is going to make it easier for
you to get burned out if you're training
really hard in the gym then eventually
it's highly likely you're gonna lose
some motivation but this kind of happens
in Cycles it's almost like Seasons
you'll get periods where you're really
into your training and you feel really
revved up and you you know can't wait to
get in the gym you're busting through
PR's all the time then you're gonna have
periods where that you just don't really
feel like it but like I said I'm not
really worried it's happened before
it'll happen again and I know that I'll
bounce back and I know some things I can
do to help myself bounce back that's
another purpose of this video I thought
it could be a kind of learning
opportunity we could talk a little bit
about burnout what's actually going on
and how we can combat it not only
prevent it but also come back from it
stronger and I think that's probably the
key to focus on that by the way is not
too belittle or undermine anyone else's
experience of burnout I'm not trying to
say like hey I'm gonna deal with it just
fine so you should too because the point
is burnout's different for everybody
different from case to Case and in some
cases it can be really severe and it can
lead to things like depression it can be
a really big issue so also don't feel
bad if you don't bounce back from
burnout but again that's where it can be
useful to learn a bit more about it and
see how best we can tackle it so if
you're interested in just learning the
strategies to prevent and deal with
burnout then you can skip forwards I'll
put a time stamp however if you do want
to hear a little bit of context and
what's going on for me personally then
stick around and I'll I'll give you that
context because you know I'm trying to
be more conversation additional and
chatty and open on the channel so for me
the biggest thing that's been making me
feel absolutely spent is my son who is
11 months old and he's going through a
sleep regression for the non-parents
watching the sleep regression basically
means that they unlearn they forget all
the stuff that they've learned about
sleep so Alex that's my son has actually
been the best sleeper you could possibly
ask for he learned to sleep through the
night after about three weeks which is
really really good and he puts himself
to sleep which again is unheard of my
daughter was much much more difficult
but lately for the last two and a half
weeks he's been waking up at two o'clock
in the morning three o'clock in the
morning and not putting himself back to
sleep and also you can't put him back to
sleep so you wake up with him at that
time and then that's the time that
you're awake from I try and like hug him
on the sofa and get him to sleep but he
crawls around and cries then you end up
sitting on the floor so he crawls around
and you just look like this my wife and
I obviously take it in turns but that
still means that every other night we're
getting you know four hours sleep max
and it does affect the one who's still
asleep this is taking its toll you know
four hours or five hours on average
every single night is not enough and
over three weeks it's really started to
yeah get too much he's actually coping
quite well with not sleeping but he's
definitely more touchy than usual and
because he's just learning to stand up
this means that he's lifting himself up
on everything and falling over and
hurting himself so you have to be on him
every single minute except for my
daughter also wants to play all the time
she wants your attention all the time so
when it's just one of us it's nylon
impossible so that's happening then at
the same time I've injured my lower back
and actually did that after I made the
video saying everyone gets injured so
that's true as well often these things
go hand in hand burn out an injury you
injure yourself because you're feeling
burned out or you're feeling a bit
injured and that makes you feel burned
out in this case I had a slightly achy
back
um I knew it was a bit risky then I
swung my daughter around the car as a
joke you know flew her into the seat
heard it a bit more it's kind of doing
okay with it I've been doing a lot of
stuff to work on my lower back strength
and it would have been fine I think but
I needed to film a deadlift for a video
I was making and I'd already written the
script I'd already told the client you
know the sponsor that it was going to be
in soon so I had no option but to film
this and I thought well if I just load
up some light weights it'll possibly be
okay so I went in did my light to
deadlift and still hurt my lower back I
felt it go but then I also needed some
videos of squats and I didn't really
have much footage of either of those
exercises so I really had to do it so
even with this bad back I then did the
squats and yeah then it really ached so
I'm also limping around sleeping worse
because my back hurts and again this has
happened before and I know how to
recover from these things and I you know
could have avoided it if my job wasn't
to train even when I'm feeling exhausted
and if I didn't have to lift a really
heavy kid in and out of a cot which is
like you bend over the cop and you lower
them down it's essentially a Jefferson
curl and there's no way to do this like
a deadlift because the bars are in the
way it's brutal at two o'clock in the
morning with a bad back when you're so
tired yeah it's an accident waiting to
happen and it did happen I do actually
have a genetic tendency towards lower
back pain pain and strain specifically
this might be to do with a variant of
the comt Gene and I found this by
looking at self-decode a service that
analyzes your DNA I'll put a link to
that in the description down below if
you're interested to find out if you do
go ahead and use that then I'll get a
commission so thank you very much even
without that though the writing has been
very much on the wall my alma which is
German for grammar she had crippling
back pain and was bed bound in her later
years my mum has extremely bad back pain
and yeah it keeps happening to me as
well so seems like it runs in the family
[Music]
my goal of course is to combat my
genetic Destiny and to be honest I'm
pretty confident I can do this this
leaves me in a bit of a tricky position
because I've got to make these videos on
a weekly basis and often they involve
like clapping press-ups and handsprings
and walking on my hands and I've got
this really bad back and whilst I don't
have to do those things there's only so
many videos I can make where I'm not
actually lifting anything or doing any
push-ups as a fitness channel so that's
been a bit of a challenge and that's the
other thing I love this channel so much
I love my job I've got the best job in
the world you guys are amazing and I
love making this content it was my dream
to get paid to work out and I also
wanted to be a programmer and someone
who wrote about science and I managed to
somehow do all those things in one job
which has just been awesome but it's
also it's actually quite stressful
because it's going so well you know I'm
getting respect from people that I
highly admire on YouTube I'm getting
noticed in the streets and I'm just like
I can't believe this is happening I've
got this cool big office but at the same
time I'm like I don't want to mess this
up and don't want it to go wrong and I'm
highly highly aware that I'm now now
responsible for my family's whole income
because my wife is a stay-at-home mum
and at the same time if I mess up then
I've kind of like screwed the best job
in the world I just keep thinking the
next video is going to be the one where
I say something stupid and suddenly
everyone realizes that they don't want
to follow me anymore yeah that's a bit
of a stress and then on top of that I've
got these sponsors which is fantastic
because it's guaranteed income during a
very uncertain economy and I'm extremely
grateful that level of sponsor I work
with and they've been fantastic but just
the fact that I've got to get these
videos to them now on time with a
deadline and I have to hand it into them
before I want to publish because they
need to check it and then send it back
and then on top of making the video
itself off to make the integration which
is an added challenge so it's become a
bit more like being employed rather than
self-employed obviously I am
self-employed but I now have to meet
demands and things
send emails which is all the stuff I'm
not terribly good at I'm more of a
creative type and someone who likes
doing push-ups I'm also working on my
new print book which is amazing but it's
an additional stress I had to hand in
the first draft last month and that was
a big rush with all the videos out to
finish as well so yeah it's been really
rapidly ticking over and it's kind of
like you have to rush but you also need
to make sure you do it perfectly and I
like to try and get home you know for 4
30 P.M every day to spend more time with
my kids before they go to bed I like to
get him for lunch and I drive my
daughter to and from preschool I don't
want to compromise any of those things
because to me that's the most important
stuff but it does mean that I have a
limited amount of time I don't be
working into the evening and not seeing
my family so I don't do that but that
means I have to cram an awful lot and
I'm stressed all the time and maybe not
psychologically present as I could be so
you know none of this is to complain I
know that a lot of people have much
harder jobs and like I say
is it just something that happens every
now and then it gets too much it builds
up and something snaps also got a few
things going on in my personal life that
aren't mine to talk about here
necessarily so yeah it just all kind of
has come to a point where I'm like you
know what this is starting to feel a
little bit
too much
and so yeah that's what I would call
burnout I haven't been able to train
because of the bad back combined with
the low energy and no sleep missing
emails kind of losing a little bit of
the creative passion that I have for the
job and I just need to take a step back
and if you're someone for whom working
out is a big part of your identity if
you train a lot then this kind of makes
burnout a little bit worse because not
only are you going to burn out faster
because you're knackered from the gym
all the time and you know fatiguing your
nervous system creating like literal
damage in your body that you then have
to repair with sleep but at the same
time you also need the energy to take to
the gym and if you don't have that
energy in the workouts aren't as good
then you're gonna feel you know a bit
low because you had a bad workout and
it's kind of again a vicious cycle
and it can be a mistake to ignore it or
to power through because you won't
recover that way because you're not
giving your body a chance to recover and
at the same time you might get injured
worse as I did that was my bad so what
can we do instead I really don't know
how honest to be with this sort of thing
to be honest but let's try something new
so I've also actually been going through
a little bit of anxiety for the first
time in my life and I think the reason
is just having kids because you know
they're so delicate and precious and you
don't want anything to happen to them
but they're also sick all the time and
you know every time one of them gets a
cough or every time one of them has a
weird rash like today it kind of sends
me through this spiral
foreign
ly something to think about is that you
can't separate your life outside of the
gym from the gym when it comes to things
like burnout and over training I've
heard it said that you know professional
athletes do all this crazy training and
the military do all this crazy training
so how can you be possibly over trained
if they're not getting over trained then
you're not getting over Train Day
typical gym rat is not going to be over
trained sounds logical the truth is that
it really depends on what you're doing
outside of the gym because these
professional athletes that's their job
they train but they also treat their
recovery like their job and they take
that just as seriously things like sleep
and nutrition and you know they don't
have another job on top of it usually
often to do not at the pro level at the
same time the military whilst yeah
they're going to be particularly burned
out and stressed they actually are
trained for that that's one of the your
goals of military training they also
select for that this is another issue
it's also individual and you might be
someone who copes better with high
levels of stress or someone who doesn't
cope as well and unfortunately if you
don't cope as well it's actually going
to be a bigger challenge for you to get
into shape because you're going to keep
burning yourself out so this is also
something to consider different people
produce different levels of
neurotransmitters for example one study
looked at the highest performing
military personnel and athletes and
found that they typically had differing
levels of DHEA and neuropeptide Y and
this was actually buffer the effects of
acute stress on the hippocampus allowing
them to retain some of their higher
level higher order cognitive function
even under extreme stress your hormones
also play a big role if you produce a
lot of testosterone then this is going
to have an impact and you know methods
to try and improve testosterone to a
significant degree are relatively
ineffectual you might raise your
testosterone by one or two percent if
you're lucky but that's not going to
make a big difference to the way you
feel unless you're taking steroids or
something else you're really stuck with
what you've got pretty much I'm afraid
so don't think that you can't be burned
out because you can and you can be over
trained at the same time think about
what you're doing outside of your
workouts if your workouts are suffering
and you're not recovering then it might
be because you know you you're a
physical laborer who works really hard
outside of the gym and isn't actually
recovering or you might even be a parent
who has a very heavy kid who constantly
needs a bobbing up and down or you might
just be extremely stressed in terms of
you know emotional stress at work and
this can also prevent you from
recovering properly you might have poor
sleep you might walk a lot alternatively
you might have the perfect scenario for
recovery so if you want to avoid burnout
and if you are wondering what caused the
burnout then take a look at your
personal life and try and find ways that
you can make it a little bit easier at
the same time I would just say
accommodate these kind of cycles and
these periods of you know enthusiasm and
drive and these periods of you know
relative malaise and low energy as you
guys know I believe in training every
single day and that can just mean
holding a deep squat for a bit or going
for a long walk or juggling to improve
hand-eye coordination there's lots of
ways to challenge yourself whether it's
physical or cognitive and these can all
be seen as a form of training it's
important to stay active to some degree
because otherwise you kind of get stuck
in such a rut you get so unused to
activity that the thought of activity
become even worse and as I talked about
in my video on feeling tired all the
time if you move it actually encourages
blood flow releases more
neurotransmitters generally helps to G
you up and get you going sometimes I go
into what's kind of like a survival mode
with my training where I'm doing just
the bare minimum to maintain what I've
already got or maintenance mode that
probably works better so instead of
trying to make gains and push through
barriers all the time it's okay to
sometimes just try and maintain what
you've got and as we know and Jeff
Nipper did a fantastic video on this
what you need to do to maintain muscle
and strength is far lesser compared to
what you need to do to get it in the
first place in fact one workout a week
According to some studies can
significantly slow down muscle loss and
may even be enough to basically maintain
it remember you always regain muscle
faster than you built in the first place
anyways thanks to some more permanent
adaptations like myonuclei and satellite
cells these are permanent changes that
will benefit you for the long run so you
come back stronger quicker so as long as
you're doing this kind of minimum amount
of training that's not not pushing
yourself or breaking yourself down but
just stimulating the muscles getting
blood in there and keeping those neural
Pathways alive then with just one
workout or two workouts a week
relatively minor you'll maintain most of
your muscle mass so you don't need to
stress about losing it because if you're
stressing about that it's just going to
add to the burnout and the feelings of
kind of malaise that you get around
burnout
obviously we want to try and promote
sleep as much as possible during these
times and that's going to be easier or
harder depending on your situation I
would love to promote sleep but it's not
really an option but what you can do is
go for like nice scenic walks which have
many other relaxing benefits you can
meditate which is fantastic for Burnout
fantastic for developing hardiness and
your ability to cope with stressful
times I would say in general getting
into nature and going for walks
particularly if you spend time with good
friends is a great way to unwind and to
let your body relax and to really
rejuvenate especially if you spend a lot
of time sitting in front of a screen
working to deadlines and things this is
just a break from all that and sometimes
it changes as good as a break I was
actually fortunate that a holiday we had
planned coincided with this period of
burnout so I've just been to the really
nice Rye with some friends and we stayed
there for a few days went to the beach
it was lovely unfortunately my sons
still woke up at two and three in the
morning and I still had a bad back and
my wife got really sick so it wasn't
like a break in the traditional sense
parents don't get to go on holiday but
it was still like I say a change and it
was wholesome and I made an effort not
to think about work and it has helped
I've been just a nice walk can have a
similar effect as can meditation
something else that can help is the
right supplements obviously protein
shake can be really useful here because
you need to provide yourself with the
building blocks to build back the muscle
at the same time we can look at things
that are going to improve your sleep I
find that magnesium three and eight is
particularly good for me this is also
great for brain plasticity and for
relaxing the muscle at the same time
inositol could in theory be really
useful this has been shown to increase
the density of neurotransmitter
receptors so in other words the parts of
the brain that receive the
neurotransmitters things like dopamine
serotonin Etc will be replenished and
built up and this is great because one
of the things that seems to correlate
with burnout is a decrease in
neurotransmitter activity particularly
the catecholamine neurotransmitters so
things like dopamine norepinephrine and
so if you have low levels of these
things then by taking inositol you might
increase your ability to use what's
available if you have a lot of these
neurotransmitters flowing through your
brain because you're feeling really
energy guys and because you're already
hitting it at the gym and you're really
doing a lot of work then your brain
becomes used to those high levels and
actually reduces the number of
neurotransmitters and then it's like you
need a bigger High to get that same
feeling of being energized so
that makes a lot of sense as to why you
might go through kind of Cycles because
you have too much those
neurotransmitters you reduce your
ability to produce them and to you know
be affected by them and so then you feel
down and low and then your body slowly
ramps and back up again and these days
as we all know we have way too much
dopaminergic activity because of our
smartphones computer games television
advertising
Etc so it's even easier for this to
happen this is a little bit of
speculation I'm taking some studies and
then running with it but it makes sense
that inositol might help some people are
worried that a nostal is going to raise
their estrogen levels because it comes
from soy but again your ability to
affect those levels is very very limited
and there's so many other things that
affect them you're not going to notice
any downsides here as an interesting
aside Bruce Lee took a nostal similarly
you might try phosphatid dilserine I'm
sorry if I'm butchering the name there I
read a lot I don't hear a lot so it
might be a mispronunciation but this one
can increase the production of those
neurotransmitters so you're increasing
the production of those things you
increase a new ability to act on these
things to be affected by those things
could just be a really nice stack there
lots of studies show that phosphatidyl
screen can be useful for combating
symptoms of adrenal fatigue and has even
been shown in one study to help to
combat acute stress induced by exercise
and then the researchers speculated that
this might mean that over time it could
help to buffer the negative impact of
training too much and becoming stressed
that way so in other words it might
protect you against overtraining we can
also take things like creatine and
omega-3 fatty acid just to boost our
energy levels as well I would recommend
that you play around with this I'm not
saying it's going to instantly cure
burnout but it has worked for me in the
past and I do notice the difference when
I'm using them I'm using them right now
and it's helping to feel a little bit
better I think could be Placebo who
knows something else that can really
help is to find something that you're
passionate about again so often we get
burned out because we're stressed out
but we don't really have the passion so
this applies to training if you're doing
the same workout over and over again and
you're not really enjoying it you're
just going through the motions but push
pushing stuff harder and harder just
because if you find something that
really excites you do some reading
whether it means switching to a
different style whether that's
calisthenics or powerlifting or whether
it means just trying a new exercise if
you can kind of get the passion back for
it and the interest so that you're
cognitively engaged in what you're doing
not just physically then this can make a
big difference as well when you're
starting to get back into the flow
something that really helps for me is to
think psyched up not psyched out so in
other words instead of trying to comfort
yourself the whole time which I think is
great to start with when you need to
back off but eventually you're just kind
of feeding into your own misery and
almost reinforcing that behavior we can
do instead is to see this as a challenge
so Everyone likes an underdog and if
you're feeling a bit tired and miserable
and achy then this is a great chance to
dig deeper and prove to yourself that
you got what it takes to bounce back
stronger ultimately it may well be that
your ability to weather the storm and to
cope when you're feeling burned out or
over trained whether it's to do with
training or with life is the big biggest
determinant in the end of your longevity
and your ultimate success because if you
give up as soon as the going gets tough
then you're gonna stop doing the things
you love and you're going to stop
progressing if you just maintain
yourself until you can regain that
enthusiasm and energy then you'll be
absolutely fine and you'll keep moving
on up it might take one step back and
two steps forwards but you're still
moving forwards overall and that's what
really matters with that said if you
don't find that your burnout is
improving if these things aren't helping
then it's extremely important that you
speak to a professional and get
professional help because burnout is not
a small matter if it gets much worse it
can lead to things like depression it'll
be much much harder to nip in the bud
ultimately so yeah try these things like
I say burnout is normal so don't fret
about it but if it gets really bad then
do speak to someone there's absolutely
nothing wrong with that like let's say
there's so many factors that go into it
everybody's different so you know don't
worry about what other people think just
do what's best for you and your goals in
the long term so yeah don't worry too
much if you occasionally lose a bit of
motivation it's fine too you don't have
to push yourself through it and just
grin and bear it it's fine to step back
have a deload week have a deload month
and to just take it a bit easier and if
you're going to kind of maintenance mode
you can maintain most of what you've
gained and it'll certainly be much
easier to get it back anyways when you
return to the gym and actually taking
that break can sometimes be a great way
to bust through plateaus
so hope you found this video useful and
interesting guys something a little bit
different I've tried to keep it
relatively minimal in terms of the
visuals just to go along with the theme
of burnout
um let me know in the comments down
below if you get burned out how you deal
with it Etc and if you are feeling a bit
burned out then welcome to the club good
luck and I hope you come back stronger
soon thank you so much for watching this
one guys and I'll see you next time
bye for now
good news though guys after filming this
and editing it I must say I have been
feeling an awful lot better still
exhausted I was up at three o'clock this
very morning uh but I am feeling hey my
back is 90 better gonna go a little bit
easy on it still for a while but you'll
see me doing one-armed push-ups most
likely next week and I imagine I'll be
back to normal then at the same time I'm
also feeling a bit of my mojo coming
back I don't know if that's because of
the supplements very possibly or it
might just be because I've had a bit
more inspiration with my videos I've had
a few new ideas and I'm kind of excited
for the channel again so like I say it
goes in cycles and I wasn't worried and
things are on the app these sleep
regressions don't last forever so
hopefully I'll be back at it full power
very soon and I've got some really cool
and exciting stuff coming to the channel
actually so stay tuned for that in fact
I'm off to go and film some of it now
speaking of sponsors that I'm incredibly
grateful to work with Squarespace has
sponsored this video and I'm incredibly
happy to say that they will be
sponsoring many more over the next year
we're going to Squarespace is actually
as stress-free as possible because
they're highly creative focused and I
massively appreciate that I also love
working with Squarespace because they
provide a really genuinely useful
product if you don't know Squarespace is
a platform that lets you build websites
and it makes it extremely easy so that
you don't need any programming
experience whatsoever in fact you can
build a website in a matter of minutes
which means that the barrier to entry is
absolutely minimal and there's no reason
that everyone can't have their own
website and while Squarespace might make
it very simple to build a website it
also doesn't limit you in any way in
fact it Powers some of the biggest
brands on the web it gives you literally
everything you could want so the ability
to create posts to schedule those posts
that they post automatically when you
want them to it has a fully featured
commenting system member management it
has tracking so you can see which pages
are performing well and why social media
integration so that you can
automatically push your posts your
social media channels and so you can
show your feeds on your website you can
choose from a nearly endless array of
themes to make sure your site looks
unique and customize them to your liking
there's loads of ways to monetize your
site as well if you want to turn into a
business such as creating members only
areas running e-commerce stores that you
can sell things and then if you don't
have all the features you need then you
can add additional features with plugins
for example you can greatly expand the
e-commerce features so that you have
global Shipping and tracking you can
manage your taxes right there on the
site genuinely anything you might need
to build a fully featured website is
available through Squarespace it's
simple it's easy it works on multiple
different platforms and yeah I can't
recommend it highly enough
visit squarespace.com if you want to
learn more and when you're ready to pull
the trigger go to squarespace.com
forward slash bioneer link down below
and you get 10 off of your first domain
or website thanks once again to
Squarespace and thanks to you guys
bye for now